[Música]
boa tarde meus queridos minhas queridas
primeiro de tudo queria agradecer à mãe
terra essa que nos acolhe agradeceu a
respiramos agradeceu só que nos aquece a
todo dia
agradeci água que bebemos e agradecer ao
pai topado e agradeceu até que se prove
o convidar para estar aqui neste momento
é com muita gratidão seu partido com
vocês um pouco da minha experiência de
vida
eu me emociono me perdoe mas se eu estou
aqui é porque é dotar deve chamar a
mostrar a unidade já dizia que eu
precisava estar aqui hoje com gratidão
gratidão
[Música]
[Aplausos]
nassim canindé vem de uma família de
oito irmãos sua cachorra e depois de
algum tempo
quatro anos de vida do nascida já
precisei deixar minha terra natal por
conta da dificuldade precisamos me
ligavam a cidade pt koff onde lá meu pai
ia trabalhar na sua inteira de miranda
por conta da grande seca que se alastra
por todo o nordeste 1988 ea gente com
muita dificuldade a gente precisava se
mudado o local de origem
naquela época os quatro anos de idade eu
já ouvia a palavra essa menina maluca
porque parece com a bisavó dela
isso me chamava muita atenção ela mesma
dizia que eu era diferente dos meus
outros irmãos e eu sempre acreditava
já os quatro anos de idade já tinha
consciência que alguma coisa um dia
poderia melhorar porque naquela época a
gente sofre muito
passava muita fome dormir no chão não
tinha quase roupa não tinha brinquedo
para brincar não tinha nada a única
coisa que a gente tinha de de fato dessa
natureza era a mata era o canto dos
pássaros
isso me levava a está muito presente na
natureza ele estava constantemente nas
matas dava muito trabalho à minha mulher
apanhava tanto porque eu saía e muitas
vezes voltava se você já ouviu falar na
palavra se a miar yawa perde se na mata
eu estava em busca de alguma coisa que
naquela época por ser tão criança não
sabia o que era
hoje eu sei que eu procurando ea preta
teve uma vez que eu passei até um dia
perdido na mata
e pra mim não passar fome eu sobrevivi
mas cabrini que tinha lá o sabre que eu
ficava em casa eu virei cabeça - peito
dela passou a fome a minhas bonecas era
eu que construí de sabor de milho pegar
o sabugo vestibular no cabelo de milho
porto e uma boneca
eu gostei a uma família havia dado leve
sabor de milho
eu acho tão lindo e eu era feliz com
todo o sofrimento chupava o dedo quando
vim à fome
eu queria brigar meu irmão botar o dedo
na boca porque eu era mais nova tinha
uns a gente era tudo pequena ainda
algumas sempre esteja ele só faz um dos
outros e aí o povo dele aqui me dá a
sensação que a fama passava a primeira
boneca que eu tive a oportunidade de
gravar meu braço
eu carreguei da menina do dono da casa
que a gente morava era uma felicidade
enorme quando natécia voltar lá nos
gastos falava cantava pintava cantiga de
ninar com ela até que um dia um
descobriu me deu a sua tão grande nem
ferro devolveu a minha boneca ainda
pedir desculpa foi uma grande do sul a
grande perda
nessa época eu tinha uns sete oito anos
eu botei na minha cabeça eu vou fazer
boneca pra mim nunca mais apanhar o
carro de boneca e quando eu tinha dez
anos comecei com um chat na boneca de
pano x muitos bonecas de bonecas a todo
mundo que não tinha bonecas ao 10 anos
eu comecei a estudar naquela época dez
anos é que eu vim pra escola
quando cheguei na escola o que me chamou
mais atenção foi do juiz de estudos
sociais porque ela falava da história do
brasil da história dos índios eu me vi
ali naquelas notações jeans
eu sou desse jeito só falta esse tocar
eu me achava muito linda naquela
história e quando chegar em casa e dizer
mamãe ela ter certeza
vai demorar um bocadinho e mais uma vez
eu não disse que essa menina maluco é
que eu achasse a cada game menina e eu
tinha consciência que eu ia realizar os
meus sonhos e o tempo foi passando e
retirar na rede que o negócio é sério é
a gente pois não preocupa
eu só tinha dois vestidos todos os dois
muito velhinho um contato remendo e se
vestir dia tanto remendo sabe que rendo
quando a roupa e ficar velho e botas
emenda vai cobrindo a cobrindo moral da
história ninguém conhecia mas quero ter
sido verdadeiro
hoje eu tô com meu vestido da minha
infância o que era carência pra mim
gerou competência na mensagem e
aparelhos na frente de vocês como eu
cheguei lá e é uma mãe se mal dizia
muito por conta da dificuldade eu dizia
mamãe calma que um dia vai melhorar
o primeiro grupo que eu assumi eu tinha
13 anos 12 a 13 anos
a minha tia era culturalmente 19 no mês
de maio
ela adoeceu não pode fazer eu de tia eu
faço eu vou fazer da venda e mais uma
vez o nome ela do dexia mina de sal vai
nada família maluca não sabe de nada não
eu briguei briguei briguei assumiu 6 de
novembro
foram 31 dias de muita animação e muita
brincadeira de roda todo dia tinha
fogueira e no final percebi eu descobri
comigo mesmo
esse é o meu primeiro grupo social e aos
14 anos o que era ruim ficou pior
eu perdi meu pai apareceu com muita
dificuldade a mãe deixou eu vim pra
fortaleza para trabalhar de babá
já comecei a dar um passo mais na frente
encontrou a família que muito me acolheu
essa família até hoje ela faz parte da
minha história da minha vida
o vínculo idade o menino germano que
hoje após 45 anos é como é que ele tenha
sido o meu primeiro filho
passou-se quatro anos a nossa família
estudei
um pouquinho a oportunidade que eu tenho
de estudar foi até a 7ª série e nem
concluir por alguns motivos
eu tenho certeza que a natureza e essa é
a minha maior faculdade foi e continua
sendo a cada dia aprendo coisa nova com
essa natureza linda que deus criou m
presente eo presente a todos nós
passaram se quatro anos da minha vida
trabalhando nessa casa voltei novamente
da pt corre pra casa da minha mãe
e lá em seguida conheci o pai dos meus
filhos e logo o agente por um pouco
tempo a gente se caso eu pensava ter
muitos filhos mas não tive muito
cansativo e 13
e um deles está no papo com você meu
filho queria dizer que eu te amo
parabéns você está aqui comigo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
então mais uma vez eu precisei me ligar
voltei pra fortaleza novamente dessa vez
publicada de menino tudo pequenininho
sem ele sem bandeira sem ele sem você
sabe o que é que ele tem nada de nada só
canais só coragem de vir mesmo o pai
dele sem querer vir eu insisti não vai
dar certo o acerto vai dar sempre na
expectativa que tudo vai dar certo ea
gente veio o sofrimento
eles não passaram totalmente fome como
eu passei mais passar um pouquinho
cansei de fazer uma farofa do olfato
dinho comprou há a farinha botar do ovo
fazer o ato tinha de comprar um daqueles
grande parte do trato dinho mas isso não
impediu do meu se crescerem
eu sempre dizia pra ele no fim nós vamos
vencer a gente morou em casa alugada por
muito tempo 17 anos depois eu me grey
mais uma vez para o jogo no sul do
recinto até hoje foi lá um grande passo
foi a descoberta de toda a minha
história que eu sonhava
chegando lá me deparei com a área
pastoral do conjunto palmeiras onde
tinha muito movimento
o primeiro movimento que dedicaram seu
movimento e cebs comunidades eclesiais
de base eu sempre acreditei no deus todo
poderoso que toda a gente é capaz de
realizar quando a gente acredita irá me
engajei na igreja
participei do movimento de mulheres
participa de pastoral da criança
e lá a gente fazer grupo que chamava
ofício de ensino das comunidades onde as
pessoas contavam a sua história conta o
seu testemunho de vida ea gente se
superando e e conseguindo viver melhor
parte dos grupos e todo mundo quer um
caminho até a índia elevou que eu sei
que eu sou eu porque eu sou doida pra
minha mãe dizer que o parecer que a
minha avó eo pai que era só eu sabia
padre chico mimosa que eu moro no timor
leste disse eu vou levar para conhecer
uma aldeia e me levou a nau de itaguarí
eles chegam na primeira coisa que eu
procurei faz jogos que eu vi
não vi nem do adeus a um pouco
não tinha hora tinha casa a gente é alta
mas mesmo assim eu me encontrei o final
de tarde para aquela menina que
procurava naquela época na mata alguma
coisa que não sabia o que era eu sabia
que era realmente a minha história
ameaça à estabilidade que estava
procurando
voltei muito gratificada com muita
gratidão de ter conhecido aquela reserva
em seguida padre chico disse mais uma
vez vou levar pra conhecer outro espaço
que latem oca para olha o projeto 4
varas
quando eu cheguei lá eu vi aquele monte
de ok eu fiquei encantado aqui é uma
aldeia na que o projeto e olhei
participei fiquei encantada disse dirceu
sabe que um dia eu ia morar na casa de
eu posso tá namorando mas eu estou com
os pés na casa de índio e foi aí que eu
conheci o professor adalberto barreto
também foi palestrante ano passado aqui
no tek ouvindo escutam na história
fiz muitas perguntas falei pra ele da
minha vontade de querer me descobri
minha história e não foi difícil porque
a e se dizendo muitas coisas positivas
começar a acontecer
eu que já tinha 1 a 1 eu que já conhecia
alguma coisa vai ver ele junto com o
projeto 4 vai a coisa melhorou
isso que é participando vai se prevendo
que o que acontece no projeto
eu poderia ter uma participação poderia
como voluntário está lá ajudando aquela
criança eu também aquelas pessoas até
porque como diz o professor do aberto da
terapia
a gente não faz mal a ninguém a gente
faz a nossa própria terapia e voltando
pra casa com aquela expectativa de
mudança com a certeza que realmente era
a índia
a primeira coisa que eu tive foi de
fazer foi mudar totalmente o meu modo de
ser
foi aí que eu lembrei quando eu era
pequeno tinha santos titular mentado eu
achar bonito assistir poderão saber um
açaí qual existe
como eu sou costureira não foi muito
difícil pois era dia de lixo segundo
teste quinta é o dia do lixo de são
cristóvão
muitas vezes eu pegar a retalho as
confecções saia bem cedinho e eu
consegui a retalho e fazer mensagens
como faço até hoje essas áreas onde são
confeccionadas não só pra mim mas com as
pessoas também que quer usar uma saia de
retalho e eu comecei a cuidar de criança
o menino já estava grande um dos meus
três mais novo já tinha nessa época três
anos eu comecei a fazer o primeiro grupo
que eu fiz com criança foi numa véspera
do dia das crianças
o meu objetivo era passar por aquela
criança que não é por eles não têm um
brinquedo que eles não iam ser feliz
a importância da felicidade não estava
no brinquedo porque eu não tinha me quer
quando era pequena nasceu era semelhante
e aí eu comecei a conversar com essas
crianças comecei a conversar no dia das
crianças com pipoca quinha comprei bosi
era costureira dar o dinheiro enquanto
eu consegui ficar com as usou duas
crianças e um grupo de mulheres eu já
passei quando a associação de mulheres
em 2005 e 2006
eu fui convidada a ser presidente da
associação de mulheres e eu digo eu vou
ter capacidade e assumiu a associação
mas aí o povo queria e infelizmente
enfrentei neve foi a eleição rotação eu
ganhei para ser presidente da associação
mulheres em movimento e aí a coisa foi
crescendo e aí a minha história foi
desvendando conhecia maria amélia que é
da missão tremembé que me fez descobrir
que eu sou dos canis de aratuba meu povo
resinar atuba
nunca morei na aldeia mas ele não me
pediu deu resgatar a história indígena
eu nunca morei mas hoje eu conheço
alguém várias partes do brasil e pra mim
aqui é resgatado era de 6 onde todos
estão aqui resgatar a nossa história e
que ia salvar neste momento nossos
parentes não só do ceará mas de todo o
brasil
aqueles que estão aqui aqueles que já se
foram lutando pela terra e na comunidade
em dia eu recebi um convite já que eu
era engajada na igreja um curso de
ministro da eucaristia a 6 67 anos sendo
o início da eucaristia vivia na igreja
aí eu disse culpado um dia que eu
precisava ser ministra na rua e o tempo
foi passando
veio com vítimas e terapeuta comunitária
já em seguida a construção da alpa de
saúde comunitária que é o desvendar da
minha história
feito de uma vez tudo se encaixando tudo
se encaixando e agente participou de
todo o processo da terapia comunitária
terapeuta comunitária
nem precisa dizer que eu faço porque na
minha história de vida tem a gente
construir a obra de saúde comunitário
quando foi no final da construção
entregar a chave fica aí que eu achava
até que um coordenador
já vai fazer 12 anos eu estou com a
chave
como eu não sei porque eu não tinha
sabedoria suficiente para ordenar o
espaço público na prefeitura eu não
estudei na universidade para ter um
certificado diz segundo lugar para me
condenar o espaço mas o tempo está
passando e eu estou lá e na hora a gente
faz com que as pessoas têm uma qualidade
de vida melhor não é a fátima que muda a
vida de ninguém
eu apenas uma ponte como terapeuta
comunitária quando as pessoas chegam lá
que conta suas histórias
ela começa a perceber que tem outras
pessoas que viveram a mesma história que
superar em casa também vou superar
o primeiro ponto que a gente levanta a
autoestima porque um ser humano sem
auto-estima é a pior via era a principal
pessoa pode ter
quando a pessoa deixa de acreditar em si
mesmo por isso que eu venci porque eu
sempre acreditei em mim sempre acreditei
na minha criança nunca perde a
dificuldade que fizesse eu dizer não vai
dar certo
é tanto que tive a coragem de te tempo
sinto tanta dificuldade mas graças a
deus então tudo bem encaminhado
e aí eu coordeno a oca até hoje com
várias terapias em 2012 eu fui convidada
pelo um congresso europeu de terapia
comunitária para dar uma palestra em
parei no congresso tem lá eu digo eu é
que vou falar aqui porque nem se a
língua deles
mais uma vez alberto não tenha medo que
eu todo celular então eu vou
você fala e eu todos a sua fala então
assim eu não tinha medo eu não tenho
medo dos convite eu não tenho medo do
desafio
eu sempre acredito que eu quero que eu
posso que eu consigo que eu realizo
foi acreditando foi lutando foi sem medo
que eu mas sim e por isso que eu estou
aqui os meus filhos eu criei 9 todos bem
encaminhado
uma assistente social um dos mais novo
termina nesse ano os estudos para ser
padre 2019
se nada acontecer terá um padrinho na
nossa família
a pobreza não deixou que meus filhos diz
grandes garrafas nas drogas
graças a deus nenhum virou dependente
químico
tudo isso foi a beleza de deus na minha
vida
a comida que eu não tinha quando era
pequena hoje eu vejo as panelas todo
cheia na área de saúde comunitário desde
o início a gente tem um almoço de quarta
feira que a gente chama o feijão
comunitário da saúde e esse feijão
permanece até hoje
então queria assim agradecer a vocês por
estar aqui e dizer pra vocês que não tem
sonho maior em extensão menor tem sono e
assim na certeza que cada canção
realizado
eu queria pedir para você ficar de pé
imaginar qual é o seu sonho
imaginar que não é grande não é pequena
é sonho e dizer como disse está os
parentes itapema
quem deu esse nós não soube dar esse
sinal está dado exato já mexe comigo
nosso trabalho é desafio já e fechou
seus olhos vamos cantar desculpa só
passar do tempo quem deu esse não soube
dizer quem deu esse nó não soube usar
esse nóis sábado meio desatento e se
nóis tá tá número exato já hoje tinha o
leste chute de chu chutava ae
oi gente de quem eu e final não soube
dar a quem telefonou não chove no estado
da turíngia
[Aplausos]
[Música]